I'm not normally embarrassed by the
extent of my subject uh at the beginning
but I I I could hardly compete with the
idea of explaining all behavior and
social activity from fundamental axioms
of physics so I'm going to focus on a
much smaller problem which is trying to
understand the visual system in the
mouse and I'll I'll motivate this uh
through the course of this talk but it
actually comes from a a deeply held
philosophical belief about research
which is if you can choose the right
problem and and dig into it uh deeply
enough then then you're likely to learn
lessons that will will inspire the
solution to other related problems and
in in fact help you even to uh be able
to formulate them and and so for those
of you who don't care about uh biolog
logical visual systems I've changed the
intro to the talk based on several of
the comments that I heard yesterday and
today uh which is about the rise of AI
in science and in our culture in general
so PR this is my attempt to get large
again and and the question is whether
these artifacts are actually doing
things like this other intelligent
machine uh that we know about uh at
least at the level of our visual systems
and and as as I'm sure everyone in this
room knows uh deep networks came uh uh
out of uh a a very crude analogy with a
very crude model from the late
1970s uh by by David Hubble and and
tourist beel uh modeling the early
visual system in in the cat and this
model has now been extended into uh uh
the foundation of much of the deep
learning aspect of modern Ai and and
there is in fact a something of a
Manhattan Project going on that wants to
build an identity between these deep
networks and the structure at least of
visual systems and and frankly I was I
was struck a lot by your comment
yesterday about whether we're writing
papers that are only to be read by
machine and uh that uh takes this
actually to to a much higher level is is
the nature of this intelligence anything
like uh uh what we would call
intelligence why I I don't know the
answer to the big question but I'm going
to try to address that at least at the
level of of uh the visual system and and
so so how might you go about this and my
my goal here is to set the stage and and
introduce our algorithmic approach to
this well there's some unknown neural
network in in say a visual ual system
and we excite it with some stimulus of
one sort or another and we we record the
activity we measure the activity and and
I believe the philosophers in this room
would call that an experiment uh and and
the question is once you do an
experiment what do you do with with all
those data uh in our case uh we're going
to deal with with the mouth because it
is the the system of choice for much of
Modern Biology and and so these mice are
mice are are pretty good at wandering uh
through the world and surviving and so
so there's there's sort of three
questions which is which are what are
the stimuli that we should use to excite
the visual system of the mouse in a
non-trivial fashion and how do we build
some notion of what the circuits might
be that are underlying that activity and
we would like to be able to do this by
analyzing the data that we acquire uh
through experiments now there's there's
of something of a history to this
subject which which is very anti Mouse
which which if you take the mouse and
put it in the laboratory as uh we would
all go to the opthalmologist and measure
the Acuity of these animals it turns out
that that mice are effectively blind
that is to say uh if I asked how well
you could see something small like say
your thumbnail held at arms length so
your thumbnail at arms length is about
one degree visual angle and the the
Acuity of a mouse with respect to that
is only less than 10% as good as being
able to see something like your
thumbnail so if a primate were viewing a
scene like the one that you see here on
the right then it would see a pattern
like this blurry mess over there so so
this says that
uh maybe the mouse is not the right
creature to be using for uh visual
experiments despite the fact that
there's so much known about it
genetically and and and biologically uh
and so many Imaging capabilities uh but
if you go down a level you see that the
the the neural Machinery in the mouse is
very analogous to the neural Machinery
in cats as huil and visel used them or
in the primate maybe maybe there's
something else that's going on here that
requires a little bit of understanding
and that is is the stimulus that your
opthalmologist would use to design your
glasses the right kind of stimulus to be
using in evaluating the visual system of
the mouse so we thought about that and
and and from a mathematician's
perspective what a mice do well they run
around in fields looking for crickets
and other things to eat so so if you
picture yourself as a mouse running
through a field there's lots of grass
and Shrubbery and whatnot at the scale
that matters to you and so as you're
running through the field you see this
kind of waterfall of Shrubbery and grass
flowing by and this led us as
mathematicians to build a collection of
flow patterns that are an abstraction of
that class of visual stimuli and
my colleague uh Michael Striker has used
these flow patterns to assess the visual
system of the mouse and there's a
there's a key data science Point here
which is the flows are much more
naturalistic than than uh the artificial
stimuli that you see on the left side of
your screen but they're also much more
amable to analysis than than natural
images which are essentially an
uncontrolled class of of stimuli uh that
you see on the right so to get the
experiments to work you need to be
somewhat cognizant of the stimuli now
how are these experiments done we we're
the mathematicians this is all done by
my colleague Michael Striker at UCSF and
the game is played as follows we need to
record from the mouse while the mouse is
running around in what it thinks of as a
naturalistic situation looking at this
these flow patterns going by on computer
screens and this is done with a very
clever uh uh scheme developed by David
tank in which you Bolt the Mouse's head
to a uh fixed object so you can insert
electrodes to do recordings but at the
same time the mouse is standing on a
ball of Styrofoam which is elevated by a
jet of air and the moment of inertia of
the Styrofoam ball is the same as is the
mouse so the mouse is running around on
this ball looking at our computer
screens we can record from his brain
because it's immobilized but the mouse
thinks he's running around through the
world or at least that's our sense of
what we think is going on now with that
setup we can evaluate the response to
these flow patterns and this becomes a
little bit technical here and I'm trying
to not be technical in this talk but you
can see from this rendition of what are
called the reop fields of the visual
neurons in the mouse's brain that
there's a lot of structure to the flow
that's at a much higher frequency than
the size of these receptive fields and
here the red lobe indicates an
excitatory and the blue lobe indicates
an inhibitory portion of the visual
field that the mouse cares about and and
to make a non-technical observation of
the summary of the data mice love these
scenes they love these visual flow
stimuli they respond at at two and a
half maybe three octaves higher in
frequency to these artificial stimuli
contrast matters a lot uh etc etc and in
fact if you look at the cells in Mouse
cortex that care only about the gradings
about the classic stimuli it's a small
percentage and so so this is lesson
number one you need to be very careful
about making sure that you're exercising
the system at least in a non-trivial way
to the problems that you have the second
is a data science problem which is once
we have this Ensemble of stimuli the
analysis question becomes much more
difficult which is how to analyze the
response of a visual system to an entire
ensemble of stimuli now we have
recordings from let's say a thousand
neurons to each of the stimuli in this
ensemble in this behaving situation and
so there is a popular approach to
analyzing this and this is right at the
heart of what's going on in
computational in the bulk of
computational Neuroscience these days
where you show the mouse the stimulus
you record from a thousand neurons you
measure the response to neuron one to
stimulus one the response of neuron 2 to
stimulus 2 dot dot dot the response of
Neuron a th thousand to and you do that
for each of the stimuli it's a high
dimensional space you reduce
dimensionality with traditional
techniques like PCA and you get what's
called a perceptual manifold now the key
thing about this perceptual manifold is
each point is a stimulus and they're in
coordinates that relate to the activity
of mice the principal components of of
the stimulus key thing each dot in this
manifold each point on this manifold is
a trial so if you imagine yourself
walking around on this as you walk on
the manifold you're walking trial to
trial to trial what the manifold is
telling you about is in the context of
the brain how do the trials relate to
one another well this is extremely
useful if your job is to decode what you
think the mouse was looking at and and
for that reason these these these kinds
of techniques are used a lot in in brain
implants and other such things where you
want to decode a stimulus from the
activity
um and understanding the visual system
however we're not out to build a
prosthesis we're out to figure out what
the circuits are these manifolds
describe which trials are similar what
we want to know is what are the neurons
doing that is to say we need something
like the inverse of that manifold so
instead of representing trials in neural
coordinates we need to represent neurons
in coordinates that relate not only to
the trials but to the individual
responses and we've developed an
approach to building this manifold and
we call it the neural encoding manifold
because it's in a sense the inverse to
the St standard decoding manifold the
key point on this manifold is
neurons live in neighborhoods where they
respond similarly to the stimulus
ensemble in time to the other neurons
around them so neurons nearby on this
manifold are likely to be involved in
functional circuits neurons far away are
doing something rather different and the
hope is that once we understand this
manifold it'll tell us something about
abstract functional circuitry which can
then tell us something about real
circuitry so here's here's the way it
looks with real data this is the striker
setup at UCSF but because as I described
it the visual system in the mouse
responds so surprisingly to these flow
stimuli that we thought we better take a
look at the input to the cortex and so
we teamed up with Greg who's now at UCLA
and so we have exactly
analogous presentations of our stimulus
Ensemble to the cortex and to the retina
of mice under comparable
conditions
and that's the siloing effect that we'll
see um so the stimulus Ensemble is of
course all the classic stimuli because
we need to relate to the activity of the
rest of the Neuroscience world but also
a collection of these flow stimuli that
represent what a mouse would be doing in
a more naturalistic setting and they're
designed so that we can titrate out
various aspects of of stimulus
properties that we think the mouse knows
uh would be interested in this is a real
version of that decoding manifold the
classic approach and you can see from
this that the different groups of Uli
form clouds in that space so it would be
relatively trivial from a machine
learning perspective to design decoding
algorithms to say what stimulus the
mouse was looking at you see the
beautiful clustering here in visual
cortex of the mouse well what does it
look like in the
retina the Clusters are even more
separate the margins are bigger the
decoding problem is easier so if you
wanted to solve this kind of problem
you're better off using a Reed than a
brain so what's going on in the brain
the brain is already doing something
much more complicated which seems to
make the classical decoding issue a
rather different one
so how we will we approach this let me
just familiarize you with the way we
present I will be presenting the data
and that is think
of a particular retinal gangan cell and
it sees a bunch of stimul Drifting by in
different directions some of these are
grading patterns some of these are flows
of various sorts and so for each one of
these we get a map which is the
direction of Flow versus the time since
the stimulus came on and you could see
here that if the if this particular
neuron was selective for this region of
visual space as the stimulus came by it
would quiet quiet quiet and you could
see that as in one of these directions
of flow quiet quiet so red means lots of
activity black means not much activity
you get a similar kind of picture in the
visual cortex except now it's a little
little bit more structured in visual
cortex neurons tend to care about
whether it's drifting this way with a
grading of that orientation or drifting
this way with a grading of that
orientation and so you get the same kind
of distribution of responses here but a
bit more refined okay this is two
classic examples you could find cells
exhibiting this behavior in the huil
visal experiments that I talked about at
the beginning what happens if you show
the entire ensemble of six stimuli and
that's why I'm going through this so you
get familiar with thinking of the
different stimulus class as one of the
positions in this array of activity for
each of the cells well that cell in V1
that I showed with the classical huil
visal response didn't care about any of
the other stimuli that's a very
classical cell those are the ones on
which deep networks are based most cells
don't respond that way in in the visual
cortex most cells for example this one
has no interest in low frequency
gradings and has beautiful responses
tuned to orientation to high frequency
gradings or or to flow patterns that
have orientation structure it doesn't
like unoriented or just dot kinetic
motion patterns at all unless the
contrast is negative okay what's going
on here here's another retinal gangion
cell this is the one I showed at the
beginning right there's those those
bursts of activity as the low frequency
grading drifted by it loves high
frequency gradings it loves positive
contrast flows it doesn't respond at all
to negative contrast flows right what's
going on here every neuron is giving a
response in different ways to this
Ensemble of stimuli this is a pretty
complicated system to begin to
understand that's why we're trying to
build this encoding manifold so that we
can begin to understand how these
properties are represented in the visual
system now the heart of the matter is
doing this for those of you familiar
with with machine learning ideas this
becomes a very technical problem in
manifold inference I'm going to skip
over all those details other than to
give you a sense of how the mathematics
Works behind this which is to say we
have a collection of neurons respon Each
of which is responding to an ensemble of
stimuli and the response is given as a
function in time so this is a tensor of
data and the question is how did it say
which points in that tensor of data are
similar to one another Well points are
going to be neurons so look at for
example neuron I over here it likes low
frequency gradings and it likes negative
contrast flows and it has a strong
transient aspect to its response to the
flows that you don't really see with the
gradings okay notice that neuron I and
neuron K are really similar to each
other in their response to the ensemble
and so we can build what's called a
kernel which measures that and this is a
very technical aspect of things but what
it says is neurons I and K should be
close by each other on this manifold now
neurons I and J which are responding
quite differently notice that I like the
negative contrast flows J didn't like
those at all J liked positive contrast
flows I didn't respond on to those at
all so I and K are close J is far away
you build a graph of these data
distances in this graph are given by
this similarity kernel in the limit as
the number of neurons gets large there's
a convergence in a certain technical
sense of that graph to a manifold and
that's what we're calling the neural
encoding manifold okay so nearby each
point is a neuron points nearby
are responding similar to The Ensemble
this is what the data really looks like
for the retina as I show it well it's
projected down into three dimensions but
as I show it even just projected down to
three dimensions you immediately see
that this is a highly clustered
representation of the neurons there are
places where the neurons are very dense
in this
representation and the places where it's
dense are separated by areas is
that are pretty empty of neurons and so
this highly clustered representation
for the retina seems to be curious
remember every point in this
representation is a
neuron so since it's a neuron we know
it's everything about its response to
our Ensemble of stimulite neurons that
are in the same cluster are by
definition near each other on the
manifold these high density areas on the
manifold so they exhibit similar
responses to similar aspects of the
stimulus Ensemble if I go to a different
cluster I find a very different profile
of responses to our Ensemble if I go to
a different neuron in that cluster it
looks the same so as I walk across this
manifold I see high density of cells
that are responding similarly boom then
a big jump into cells that are
responding differently boom a big jump
into cells that are responding
differently and I can keep doing that I
can walk over the whole manifold and I
can keep doing
that why would you expect that to be the
case it turns out that these clusters
are not arbitrary they relate to what's
known about the structure of the retina
which is retinal gangling cells are
organized into classes in the mouse
there's thought to be maybe up to about
40 such classes it's thought that in in
human primates there's maybe 20 such
classes in these 40 classes they have
names they have characterization they
have properties the neurons in these
clusters are representing all those
properties okay this is not to
say
that not much was added to retinal
physiology but I would like you to read
this as saying this is a confirmation in
some sense that our algorithms are at
least doing something appropriate with
regard to neural activity because it's
learning in a completely unsupervised
fashion much of the structure of what
was known about retinal gangan cell
properties okay V1 visual cortex the
first area that processes visual
information in human primates it's in
the occipital lobe way back here in the
back of your brain and what do these
look
like the manifold for the cortex is to
the extent that we can characterize it
completely continuous you notice there's
this beautiful high-dimensional
structure it's hard to tell in this low
dimensional projection there's this
beautiful high-dimensional structure
with this low dimensional Arm coming out
of the side
there were several years of mathematical
and computational work in F trying to
develop algorithms for manifold
inference that work properly in what are
called non-pure manifolds in mathematics
manifolds where in it where the data
change their local intrinsic Dimension
how will we characterize these
continuous manifolds well each point is
a neuron so we could stand on a neuron
we can look at its properties and then
we could start so for example stood on
this neuron over here we can look at its
properties as we start to walk along a
geodesic on this manifold we can
encounter other neurons and they have
different properties and you see as long
as you go along pathway one as cartooned
in this diagram we go from neurons that
prefer all the stimula I highly
promiscuous with regard to our stimulus
Ensemble to neurons that really only
like flow patterns and so we go from
neurons over in this corner that like
everything to neurons over here that
really only like flows what if we went
along the opposite and opposite
direction on this manifold we see that
again the properties change but as you
walk along that direction what you lose
is selectivity for low frequency
gradings respons responsiveness to low
frequency gradings well we can
characterize many aspects of the
structure of the physiology here that's
not what this talk is about I just want
you to get this kind of picture of how
beautifully continuous this structure is
and how we can characterize various
aspects of it remember in the beginning
I talked about the importance of the
stimuli the difficulty of working only
with the classical lowf frequency
gradings is these are the neurons that
care about those primarily it's only
this low frequency arm so a lot of this
visual physiology is based on one
actually quite special branch of the
manifold of neurons in visual cortex
these neurons over here on this side
that liked everything they're primarily
inhibitory interneurons because and and
in fact it's known that there there are
many properties of inhibitory inner
neurons that lead them to respond widely
to different classes of stimuli we can
take this on and on and we
can characterize many physiological
properties about the distribution and
densities of neurons at different layers
how they're related to each other that's
all visual
Neuroscience why would you expect this
topological diversity that we found in
these two manifolds to arise this is
this is a a real segregation in the
nature of the computations going on well
what one of the areas we work on in my
building a lot is spectral graph Theory
so here's spectral graph theory in 3
seconds okay if you have a collection of
neurons that are tightly coupled to each
other in a functional Network then the
manifold corresponding to that graph
will be a a a dense uh continuous little
cluster if you have several of these
circuits and they're distinct from one
another then you'll have a discontinuous
manifold represented in the stimulus
response extrinsic
coordinates if you start to add some
weak coupling between these then some of
these islands start to connect up to
each other a little bit so you have a
big island structure with some weak
interconnections in between them and we
think that's what's going on in the
retina the weak iner Connections in the
retina are what are called Amrine cells
or Gap junks between retinal gangion
cells Etc we know a lot about the
physiology and Anatomy that could
underly that in cortex the game is
completely different zillions of neurons
are connected to zillions of other
neurons and the situation is much higher
dimensional much richer much more
densely interconnected so all this makes
a lot of
sense that's the intro that's the
science that we care about here's the
part that may be relevant for you right
I said at the beginning we have these
deep deep networks we started work with
visual networks but we're yeah there
there's a lot more to be said so we can
now ask this question not at the level
of does a unit in a deep Network
resemble a unit in the retina or a unit
in the brain but does the topology of
the encoding manifold in the artificial
Network represent one of these
structures okay I won't embarrass
anybody by asking okay so here's what
you do the first question you're worried
about I know is well is AI an
appropriate object for us to be working
with because the fact that we can
technically interrogate it exactly the
same way that we interrogate the
biological data isn't so much the point
is it appropriate so what are these de
deep networks this is reset 50 a a a a
classic uh computer vision Network it's
trained on this famous library of of
natural scenes called called imag net uh
there are millions of them and it has
this spectacular ability to classify uh
in instances of these scenes into for
example spiderwebs or one of a thousand
or so other categories this has been uh
all over the cover of nature it's been
all over the cover of the New York Times
you all know this story okay so we can
feed it our stimuli they're they're just
images we feed it our stimuli and if for
example we look at the activity across
the layers of one of these networks you
we see that for imag net like patterns
or our patterns we get similar kinds of
activity distributions okay what's the
output these networks happily classify
our stimuli as for example positive
contrast flows are spider webs and and
resnet does that with
93.5% uh confidence so so we think
that's with regard to uh I don't know if
that's a prediction or a causation but
uh that's a pretty confident uh
prediction of uh that's pretty confident
estimation of one sort or
another what does the manifold look
like it's even more clustered than the
retina remember the way I showed
individual so in this case we call them
units rather than neurons because
they're they're the equivalent in in uh
these deep networks if you were to
interrog look look at the responses
plotted the same way for one of these
units you'd say Ah that's that's pretty
similar to the kinds of units some of
the kinds of units that we saw in the
visual system do they tile space the way
that retinal gangling cells do yes they
do there's a beautiful tiling of space
in the same way that retinal gangan
cells tile space but in retrospect that
shouldn't be a surprise because all
these tricks that are used to make these
networks trainable like weight sharing
are in fact imposing that uh as a
condition so so even though individually
these things kind of look like
neurons
globally they look and enjoy the
properties of something more like a
retina than like a brain these are Big
retinas these are not little
brains you can go across different
layers different
uh networks Etc same thing holds so what
I tried to illustrate by taking this
deep dive into the visual system is
building up a an infrastructure for
understanding populations of neurons
responses
at in to an ensemble of stimuli across
time the full set of data that you need
to worry about leads to very different
ways of thinking about things and opened
a direction into comparing deep networks
with with retinas with
V1 very specific retinal gangan cell
types look very much like certain of the
units in these deep networks V1 is
distributed very very differently V1 is
this continuous manifold and we think
that it's that continuous manifold that
forms the substrate out of which the
emergent phenomena that priia I think
would call cognitive activity uh can
emerge that's not the case in uh the
retina uh from these algorithms you can
compute dimensionality you see the the
lowest dimensional objects are the ones
from the artificial networks the
intermediate Dimension stuff is the
retina which has some of this Amrine
cell mediated Behavior introduced but
cortex even the first visual area of
Cortex is uh drastically different uh
this was a big team effort we we did uh
the computation work here Mike's group
at UCSF did the uh uh cortical work Greg
field at uh was it Duke now was at UCLA
did uh the retina stuff and I'd like to
just uh underline the fact that this was
a spectacular collaboration between
experimentalists of different breeds and
theoreticians of different breeds and uh
we think that's really the future of of
all this thank you than you so
much thanks for cracking open one case
where you have managed to decode what
reset actually does with spatial you
know broken up how the inference
actually happens within rest net by
mapping it on to actually vetal cells
real physical entities so cracking open
that proverbial black box that we've all
talked about so questions Joe and then
thanks one of the things I really like
about this this setup is the way that
you've got not just a changing V you
know visual flow but also more or less
correlated with the movement of the
mouse even though the mouse is stable
because of the ball Arrangement but I'm
curious whether there's any you know
what the arrangement is for the you know
for figuring in the Mouse's head and eye
movements which of you which are not
constrained I taken right which are
clearly part of of of the actual
tracking of changing visual you know you
know your movement in relation to the
movement around it is really important
in Vision so how does how does that play
into this kind of project oh so great
question uh uh we worried about that a
lot and the head is
fixed but the eyes the eyes the eyes can
move so so Mike recorded eye movements
and then Greg who did an misogynist
recording with pieces of retina move the
stimulus around as if it were being seen
through those eye movement so that
correlated to the eye movements that's
that's really cool and in fact we use
actual eye movement oh yeah that's that
would be the
point hi thanks for all the great talk
uh so could you repeat I missed how did
you pick three as the uh embedding
dimension of the lower dimensional
manifold and also how did we pick three
oh oh because three makes for a nice
video I don't I don't really know how to
display four dimensions and also did you
uh like we know a lot about the
intrinsic dimension of these
manifolds cool and also you happen to
look into uh since you were looking in
the topology of that manifold did you
look for non-trivial homology do any
topological analysis other non-trivial
Cycles like in those things that are
branching out yeah no th thus far yeah
so uh thus far we've been able to
characterize uh uh only certain aspects
of the topology because we're restricted
to we have about, 1500 neurons from the
retina about 1500 from the cortex and if
we start to look for uh uh things like
persistent hology and that other stuff
that induces an artificial clustering on
all this uh by the way that
neighborhoods are grown so we actually
experimented some with those techniques
but have not been using
them thanks so much for your talk um I
had a question about the kind of
implications or Consequences of your
results so are you thinking of this as
um something about the architecture of
the neural network as deciding this or
is it something about the problem that's
allowing the architecture to take on
this kind of retinal neuron versus right
yeah we well well they're coupled right
the the the retin has a very particular
cyto architecture the cortex of the
Mouse has a very particular cyto
architecture that there there are
certain macroscopic details of the py
architectural organization of the mouse
that do not have certain properties of
of uh Advanced primates Advanced mammals
actually like like primates or cats
which are called orientation columns and
other such uh activities so one of the
technical motivations for this work from
the physiology side is in order to do
the geometric processing that it's
thought that orientation hyper column
support do you need the hyper column
organization and because that's lacking
in the mouse except at a crude
statistical level and what this what
this implies is no you do not need that
organization at least at the level of
the first visual area of course there's
much higher level stuff going on beyond
what I talked about here but maybe next
year any other quick
questions thanks Steve
again